Did you hear that?
Canada has,
they're banning whale and dolphin captivity.
I think it's great.
I think it's great to,
it apparently just passed.
I mean,
how about blackfish?
One documentary and it like kind of,
I think initiated a movement.
Oh,
for sure.
Yeah.
People didn't know they needed to do you just see it in a digestible form
instead of having to go seek it out and read articles about it and news reports
instead of that,
they get to see it.
There it is in a very digestible format.
He go,
oh my God,
this is chaos.
This is horrible.
This is it.
This is an atrocity.
You're taking these incredible animals that are probably some of the most
magnificent creatures that evolution has ever created,
and you're putting them in a fish tank.
You're putting them in a swimming pool.
There's their fins go limp.
Yeah.
That's crazy.
Well,
it actually,
if you think about the killer whale,
I mean that's the king.
Yeah.
Does a crazy video that I just watched yesterday of one killing a beach seal it
injured the seal and the seal tried to make it over into and it literally
beached itself smashed this seal on those just blood everywhere and these a
bunch of people were standing around watching and going,
Holy Shit.
And then it flopped it's way back into the water and swam off.
It didn't eat it.
Yeah.
Okay,
good.
Well that's what I,
I mean listen,
that's the thing about nature,
right?
It's,
it's,
it's kind of brutal but it's not personal.
Like the see the,
you know the whales not like,
you know that sealed gave me kind of a funny look.
I'm going to go and give it to him.
It's like,
oh there's some food.
Did you ever see them one more in they're on the iceberg and they look,
oh that bugger is still holding on and they push it again and there was a mother
teaching it's calves at a hunt to mark that she was setting it up,
like showing like you can make them slide like watch this will slide.
Well,
I was listening to my friend Steve Romanellas podcast,
and he was talking about the difference in the orchids in the Puget sound and
that their local orchids,
which are,
uh,
essentially,
salmon specialists and they don't eat animals.
They don't eat,
um,
marine mammals.
But then there are other ones that travel into the area and they are marine
mammal specialists.
So they,
all they eat is like seals and,
and,
uh,
and things along those lines.
And they have a totally different language.
Totally don't understand each other.
They don't interact with each other at every pod has its own language.
It's crazy.
They,
they put a whale in captivity once and it was night eating because they didn't
know it was a seal eating well,
not a fish eating well.
And so at [inaudible] I used to joke,
can you imagine like,
okay,
Suzy and Billy,
we're going to go watch the,
you know,
the Orca Shampoo and then the trainers,
they're like throwing at seal.
Like that would not work out well.
Like,
Yay.
Do that trick again.
Give it a slab of cute little animal.
So it's,
uh,
they're very complex.
Yeah.